i mean that that's
yeah
it's understandable but in a match
situation the only way you can win is by
winning so you have to you know if you
get a good position you have to try and
push it as much as you can one thing
that you mentioned the niche is not
doing
enough really and i think uh liam went
for this kind of ending and it was yeah
i mean that bishop retreat was just
negative wasn't it a negative idea it
was just forcing this type of george
position and look how symmetrical this
is now the horn structure the kings
but is just going to move his king back
and forth one of my criticisms is that
earlier on when he had the bishop i feel
like yeah okay ultimately it was a draw
but he could have pushed it a little bit
harder here this was just easy stuff for
magnus i saw two pack up there i did two
yeah
as well maybe
listening to podcasts while playing in
one of the top tournaments in the world
that's impressive for game two between
magnus and liam it is also a draw they
are still tied after two games in their
match